some breaking news to bring you max
mosley the
former president of motorsports world
governing body the fia
has died aged 81. mosley became fia
president in 1993
after serving in previous administrative
roles in motorsport including
within formula one he served three terms
as president
before standing down in 2009. his death
has been confirmed today
by the ex-formula one chief executive
bernie
eccleston who has said max was like
family
to me we were like brothers i'm pleased
in a way because he suffered for too
long
mosley who was born in london on april
13
1940 was the son of the 1930s british
fascist leader
sir oswald mosley in 2008
he won a privacy case against the news
the world newspaper after it
printed photographs and published videos
uh published video of his involvement
in a sailor masochistic sex session it
was
reported by the newspaper as a
sick nazi orgy but justice zidi found
no evidence of nazi themes in his
judgment he also said there was no
public interest defense in the
clandestine
recording of the session max mosey went
on to be a
campaigner against press intrusion but
max
mosley the former president of the fia
has died at the age of 81.